[Music]
it's 1130am in Beijing nerves are frayed
it's nearly lunchtime and finding food
is all that matters whether it's takeout
or eating in the lunch break is a vital
part of the work day in China more
important some say than any meeting mein
Sohn and wan shang have no time to leave
their dance studio so they order out
with a nap they could enjoy home-cooked
meals delivered by women living in the
neighborhood miss jia lives just a few
streets away and she receives the order
six different dishes have been ordered
all of which she'll prepare in her
kitchen at home she's been retired for
eight years not unusual in a country
where women often finish working at 50
wassu what's we my daughter says I
should do this as long as I can she
loves my food she's married now and has
her own home and I'm alone here that is
how I'm able to cook food for others
prepare food for my customers yeah well
yeah well maybe in it so that everyone
can try my food so what's other made
that shitty stinky tofu a la mama gaea
sometimes she prepares more than 40
meals a day just as mother would make an
inexpensive to just three to five euros
a box
most internet startups are located in
the up-market district of Wang Jing park
in Beijing this is where the home-cooked
app was launched 18 months ago in the
beginning the apps designers simply
asked housewives and supermarkets
whether they would like to cook for them
now there are more than 50,000 private
chefs cooking dishes from their home
provinces and more than a million
customers who want to eat them eardrill
thought Rogers uber and Airbnb are apps
where individuals offer a service and
these were started in America but as for
food no one thinks more about food than
the Chinese it's very important to us so
it's not surprising that an app where
individuals offer meals cooked in their
homes was conceived in China we are
proud of it so that's always density to
the heart that is y su Qi hmm lunch is
served everything is tested thoroughly
from menus to hygiene to the ingredients
every day at least ten dishes from
private cooks are tested by the apps
founder ton Jin now we'll make you look
damn sure that this is always how we do
it we all come from different regions in
China so different meals are ordered and
everyone can try it this is the best
part of our job a key part of the app
success is Beijing's army of food
couriers they deliver around the clock
but form is Gia it's the personal touch
she delivers the food herself
on her electric scooter she is quick to
reach her customers
the food is here in the dance studio
everyone knows her the young dancers
order food from her at least once a week
ms gia delivers good food to happy
customers squid in garlic leaves and
stinky tofu just two of the favorites so
we also want the developers must have
had us in mind when they created this
app we have moved away but what we order
makes us feel closer to home babe is in
the dolly they don't gotta do it
yourself i order food from her so often
that she knows exactly how I like my
food prepared she knows that I don't
like it made with too much oil she is
just like my mother a short break in the
afternoon and ms gia reads the feedback
from her clients 5 stars all around
slather the food was hot and tasty she
brought it by personally it reminded me
of the food my mother made from is Gia
there is no better compliment